welcome to this video playing sallisaw
NC to make a gap that's Jamaica so what
am I going to do here do I know the
skyline ever play them maybe go some
Kings Indian style case playing them and
the Tory attack which is very solid of
course I'm going to attack that center a
little bit see what happens Oh III and
HD that's a kind of playing it in a
super safe fashion it looks I know it
looks a bit wow just wow huh what the
heck yeah
looks very strange let's see can I i can
just prepare 5 of course this is a
simple way of trying things i can also
play h5 this is an interesting move
let's do that it's kind of interesting
Bishop takes Bishop txg takes King g7
sacrificing a pawn form for many good
squares now group h eight comes and the
dark squares on the white side are
terrible this is well known type of pawn
sacrifice ok that's an interesting way
to play it on you does not want to take
on g6 so what now I can try to put the
bishop on F for improving it maybe f5 in
some situations but it's really not a
position for a 5 here to be honest so
I'm putting it here ok so what now I can
just take the age three pawn it will be
a terrible decision I believe it also
fits developing develops develops this
this piece so let's take that
and prepares rook c8 so he's attacking
the bishop interesting up shall take
there I mean there's no real reason to
take the night maybe yeah maybe night
can come to g3 now i come i'm taking
focusing on ponder and temple play him
just being quick with my pieces his King
doesn't really have a safe place to go
oxy 8 so is he coming with night f5 yeah
maybe is it's not super terrible if it
happens I just wonder ok let's go f5 so
that's basically ignored 95 I'm not sure
that this was right but my adheres to go
night at five check night x e f g five
and trying to play on the dark squares i
also have king f6 in that case the king
is pretty safe there you can take on g6
first but then I'll together then I can
take with the night Wow b5
ok let's go away for four Queen 85 check
and Roxy three ok went went away from
that hmm gee I wonder
I wonder if I should still take on g3
area it would be great for any kind of
endgame to take I'm still doing this
rooks III is just nice if I can get it
in maybe now this year this is possible
ok anyway I'm taking here and then night
h5 oh yeah ok now Knight takes Knight f5
king of 696 is a bit annoying yeah
really
ha what a shame I didn't really evaluate
can I go rook c3 here first by the way
and kick its Queen back right age 50
gauge 5g takes age 7 or you can play
that hmm that's a shame really then I
should have taken the night probably
right h5 check mmm just make any sense
to sacrifice the exchange for Luke's III
it's not terribly bad but time money if
I go there it takes it then queen of
three ok
so possibly Queen gvoice coming so I
want to want to have this this ready the
caption be filed with check so I'm
running oh really check if i take now
why is this working I Queenie six
Queenie six
what a shame I was just a fantastic
position for me I didn't see Queenie six
at all ah what a shame what a shame well
so it was really can shine is for me ya
can't lose on that lap resign yeah so
let's get see how I could have could
have punished this I'm in here in a very
nice shape here Keeks so I mean okay
there are a couple of improvements
before that but this just must be
excellent for black I don't don't
believe this one bit the computer just
gives me a slight edge but ok now it
gets deeper and it climbs the evaluation
mm yeah maybe I should make a kind of
prophylactic move sometimes king of ale
or something ok and and here I don't
believe this at all Queen a fine this
and Roxy three wins yeah yeah I saw and
I saw the move but I thought you can do
this this and this move I shoot I forgot
about this move yeah okay yeah I'm just
winning ah so yeah okay he has to go
back then and then this does win yeah
why exactly does it win I mean besides
the fact that it looks horrible why but
why is the direct wind takes Queen be 64
gauge tomb yeah it really couldn't work
what wide was doing here with dark
squared weaknesses and and and so on and
so I can directly win with Roxy 3 I saw
them why I didn't see I didn't see that
this was the problem of course
or this this yes and that when i take
it's a check but i forgot that i can go
here i can just go to evade this was the
reason why i didn't play Lucas III yeah
it's all about this one this one
position I took 50 seconds for that
that's really bad yeah okay here to be
honest I was thinking I can still do
this but it's not working at all i think
he can take and do this okay Quincy
three so let's play about going to the
engine okay and this is a equal yeah I
mean I shouldn't be so bad for me the
remaining pieces are kind of okay look
aged three assembles that keeps it equal
and this is losing you too green g4g
found immediately yeah I didn't see
Queenie six coming that's a problem
Quincy 7s also came but this is the main
move of the computer with an equal
evaluation now it gives look a 2 with a
slight advantage this is a kind of move
Adam human never place a rock hm Quincy
several assaults move that also looks
kind of logical getting them go to king
g2 with a slight edge yeah okay okay
it's after go rook c3 end and just a win
but I miscalculated that quite badly
okay well thanks for watching